we're told violet and lennox play an
elaborated
version of rock paper scissors where
each combination of
shape choices earns a different number
of points for the winner so
rock paper scissors the game of course
where
rock beats scissors scissors beats paper
and paper beats rock
and then they give us this elaborate
version right over here when violet wins
she gets two points
when lennox wins with rock she gets
three when lennox wins with paper she
gets two points
when lennox wins with scissors she gets
one point and if they choose the same
shape nobody gets any points because no
one wins that round
complete the matrix so it represents
their scoring system
it shows the number of points violet
gets a negative number means lennox gets
those points
where rows are violet's chosen shape and
columns are lennox's chosen shape so
here we have the matrix right over here
i encourage you
to pause this video and see if you can
have a go at this on your own if you
have a piece of paper in front of you i
encourage you to get a piece of paper
all right now let's do this together so
how many points remember this matrix is
how many points violet gets and if
lennox gets points then it's a negative
for violet so if violet chooses a rock
and lennox chooses a rock so that is
this entry right over here what's going
to happen how many points is violet
going to get
well if both players choose the same
shape nobody gets
any points so if they get both get rock
rock we'll get a zero right there
and we also know that's going to be this
true if violet picks paper and linux
picks paper you're going to get a zero
point for violet there
and if they both pick scissors that
entry there you're also going to get a
zero
all right now what if violet picks rock
and lennox picks paper
what should i put there pause the video
and think about it violet pix rock and
lennox picks paper
well we know that paper beats rock
so this is a situation where lennox wins
with paper
and so that's this scenario right over
here so lennox will get two points
so if lennox gets two points remember
this matrix is what does violet get
violet gets negative two points right
over here because lennox got em
all right now what about this entry what
does that represent
well that represents violet picking rock
and lennox
picking scissors and we know that rox
rock beats scissors so this is a
situation where violet wins
and we know whenever violet wins she
gets two points
so this will be a positive two points
right over here
now what about this entry what does that
represent
well that represents violet picking
paper and lennox picking rock
and we know that paper beats rock so
this is another situation where
violet wins and she gets two points in
any scenario where she wins
so that's two points and now what about
this one over here
pause this video and think about what
number goes there
well this is a situation where violet
picks paper and lennox picks
scissors we know scissors beats paper
because it can
cut it up i guess and so lennox has one
with scissors
and we see here we'll do a different
color lennox wins with scissors she gets
one point
so you might be tempted to write a one
here but remember that's lennox getting
a point
so this is all about how many points
does violet get and we said that would
be
negative one points if it's going to
lennox
and then let's think about this last row
here
what does this entry represent and what
number should go there pause the video
and think about it
well this is violet picking scissors and
lennox picking rock
now we know that rock beats scissors
because i guess it can bash it up
and so lennox in this scenario has one
with rock
and we know i'll pick another color here
when lennox wins with rock
she gets three points so lennox is
getting three points here this matrix is
all about what does violet get so we
want to put a negative three here
because that's three points for
linux remember a negative number means
linux gets those points
and one last entry what do you think
should go there well this is violet
picking scissors
and lennox picking paper so we know that
scissors
beats paper because it can cut it up and
we know that in any situation where
violet wins because she won with
scissors here she gets two points
so that is two points just like that
so we filled in the matrix and now we
have to answer this question assuming
lennox picks her shape entirely at
random
what shape should violet choose to
maximize her chances of getting the most
points
so pause the video and see if this
matrix is helpful for figuring out the
answer to that
all right so this obviously isn't an
exercise on probability but just as a
little bit of a review
one way to think about it is when violet
picks rock
here are the scenarios here are the
outcomes that might happen
now they're telling us that lennox picks
at random
so there would be a one-third chance
that lenox picks rock one-third paper
one-third scissors and since these are
equally likely because they're saying
that
that linux is picking at random you can
get the what is sometimes known as the
expected value here
by taking the average of these three
numbers another way to think about it
it'll be 1 3 times 0
plus 1 3 times negative 2 plus 1 3 times
2. if you want to go dig deeper into
expected value there's a lot of that on
khan academy but we can really just take
the average of these numbers add them up
and divide by 3 is another way to think
about it
and so here the expected value is going
to be
if we take the sum we get 0 plus
negative 2 plus 2
well that all sums out to 0 divided by 3
you get to 0.
so i'll just write this 0 here as the
expected value when violet picks
rock and lennox picks at random now in
this
second scenario let's take the average
if we add the all three of these up you
get two plus zero plus negative one
which is one divide by
three you're gonna get one third as the
expected value
of the points for violet and then in
that last scenario
if you add all of these up you get
negative 1
divided by 3 is negative 1 3. so it
looks like the best expected value for
violet assuming that lennox is going to
pick at random
is to go with paper you have a positive
one-third expected value
so what shape should violet choose to
maximize her chances of getting the most
points
paper now of course that's assuming
lennox always picks it random
obviously if lengths catches on that
violet keeps picking paper
linux would adjust their strategy but
that gets a little bit deeper